ce soir on vous amène au coeur de
l'opération
monsieur chen monsieur tschaen c'est un
personnage fictif qu'on a créé pour
mener une expérience en caméra cachée a
encore le but de monsieur shell c'est
d'obtenir un visa pour le canada en
passant par le programme des immigrants
investisseurs du québec
ils sont des milliers d'étrangers
fortunés à avoir obtenu leur résidence
permanente au canada en passant par ce
programme québécois
grâce à ce programme là on investit des
centaines de millions $ dans nos pme
depuis trente ans les gouvernements
successifs ont louangé ce programme mais
la réalité c'est que très peu de ces
immigrants investisseurs s'installe
vraiment au québec
le programme québécois des immigrants
investisseurs est une magouille du début
à la fin de ce programme des migrations
ils ont jamais eu l'intention vraiment
de ce sale et d'anciens fonctionnaires
sonne l'alarmé
ce qui me préoccupe le plus c'est de
rentrer des personnes qui ont des
pratiques d'affaires et lycée voire
mafieuses avec monsieur chen et non
caméra cachée on va les rencontrer des
avocats des consultants en immigration
notamment des québécois qui vont lui
expliquer comment tromper le
gouvernement du québec
frédéric zajac et francis plourde nous
présente ce soir la face cachée de ces
visas doré notre terre et il m'a dit non
bienvenue à cette douzième saison d'
enquête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
boutiques haut de gamme casino club
huppé voitures de luxe singapour est
devenu un terrain de jeu pour les ultra
riches
c'est une des villes comptant la plus
haute concentration de
multimillionnaires sur la planète
le lieu parfait pour les conférences
portant sur les stratégies de migration
mondiale et de gestion de fortune une
industrie où les plus riches de la
planète peuvent s'acheter des visas ou
des passeports
une multitude de pays en échange
d'investissements un marché au potentiel
gigantesque même sur parle de migration
par investissements la plupart des gens
ni migrent pas mais s'ils doivent le
faire ils le peuvent et avoir un
passeport européen comme le veut le
cliché c'est l'ultime police des
dizaines de pays dont de nombreuses îles
des caraïbes et des états européens sont
en compétition pour vendre leur
citoyenneté ou leur statut de résident
permanent
en échange d'investissements et c'est le
canada il québec qui ont été les
pionniers de toute l'industrie et le
canada a une par une presse un peu
particulière dans le monde de
l'immigration puisque effectivement le
canada au fédéral ou au niveau du québec
sq a été le premier au monde avec cette
composante d'investir pour avoir la
carte de résident permanent
on a toujours beaucoup de demandes pour
le canada pourquoi l'éducation le
système de santé la sécurité des
transports
le canada a rempli tous ces critères
horse mais les programmes de visa doré
comme on les appelle font maintenant
l'objet d'une vive controverse
outre atlantique en réalité ces
programmes permettent aux criminels et
aux fraudeurs de blanchir leur argent de
se refaire une virginité est importé
leur trafic au centre de l'espace
schengen
au canada le fédéral a mis fin à son
programme immigrants investisseurs en
citant des raisons de faible rentabilité
le québec est ainsi devenue la seule
porte d'entrée via un visa doré pour le
canada par le passé on a vu des
criminels et des fugitifs de haut rang
utiliser ses programmes pour entrer au
canada
je ne nie pas que les immigrants
investisseurs sont corrompus en général
mais que les gens corrompus ont tendance
à avoir recours à ces programmes
quels sont les risques potentiels liés à
la sélection ces richissimes
d'immigrants et quelles sont les
retombées réelles du programme québécois
à québec les gouvernements successifs
ont vanté les mérites du programme des
immigrants investisseurs
depuis sa création en 1986 c'est un
programme qui depuis l'année 2000 génère
plus de 800 millions de dollars à
refonder c'est avec eux on a eu une
rentabilité sur investissements l'acte
est vraiment intéressant si sur le plan
économique le gouvernement le décrit
comme un succès sur le plan
l'immigration c'est tout autre chose
[Musique]
pour l'avocat jean françois harvey un
des pionniers l'industrie l'échec du
programme sur le plan de l'immigration
est largement connue d'un secret de
polichinelle 5 % sinon plus je serai
prêt à dire 95% des gens ne restent pas
au québec
pourtant la création de liens d'affaires
entre le québec et l'asie était un des
objectifs principaux du programme
on pensait bien que les gens qui
appliquée sur ce programme là s'établir
et chez nous qui commencera à faire des
affaires
surtout qu'ils créeraient des liens avec
leur pays d'origine
et ça peut être le cas avec légende
encore malheureusement hong kong est
rapidement devenu la plaque tournante du
recrutement des immigrants investisseurs
même si en réalité la plupart d'entre
eux n'ont aucune intention de
s'installer au québec on y trouve une
lucrative industrie de l'immigration
québécoise
chaque dossier représente des dizaines
de milliers de dollars en commission que
se partagent des consultants des avocats
et des intermédiaires financiers
car pour être admissibles au programme
les candidats doivent obligatoirement
signer une entente avec un intermédiaire
ou un courtier
reconnue par le québec selon une étude
de 2011 ces acteurs se partageaient le
tiers des profits générés par le
programme
c'est dans cette tour du centre ville de
ankang que se trouvait le bureau du
gouvernement du québec
jusqu'à l'an dernier la majorité des
candidats au programme devait y passer
une entrevue de sélection
suzanne ethier a été sous-ministre
adjoint du ministère des migrations du
québec au milieu des années 2000 de tous
les bureaux du québec à l'étranger
qu'elle supervisait c'est celui de hong
kong qui lui causait le plus de maux de
tête
particulièrement quand des candidats
était refusé c'était un bureau où il y
avait toujours des pressions politiques
des pressions des consultants demandait
toujours des révisions les intervenants
brigitte van khôi tremblay a dirigé le
bureau de l'encan de 2006 à 2009 quand
un bureau traite autant de dossiers qui
traite de sa d'argent aussi importante
c'est sûr que les intermédiaires ne vont
pas rester passif donc unités para que
j'ai des pressions pour qu'ils puissent
avoir un accès particulier au directeur
ou conseiller essayer de pouvoir
influencer dans le sang ce qui les
intéresse en 2005 jean françois harvey a
plaidé coupable à cinq chefs
d'accusation d'avoir fait du lobbying
auprès de fonctionnaires du ministère de
l'immigration du québec alors qu'il
n'était pas inscrit comme le beast on
nous faisait s'inscrire au jeu des
lobbies parce qu'on reconnaîtra comme on
enregistre de s'inscrire ou a été un peu
et et 400 dollars pour sa survie et bien
en fait jean françois harvey a dû payer
plus de 3000 $ en frais amende pour ces
infractions
avez vous déjà eu affaire avec
jean-françois oui oui c'était entre
autres un de ceux qui plusieurs fois ma
envoyer ces lettres disons de deux
plaintes et que j'ai remis à sa place
[Musique]
en 2005 des soupçons de corruption même
pesé sur le directeur du bureau du
québec à hong kong
il a fait l'objet d'une enquête interne
qui n'a pas pu démontrer sa culpabilité
il a tout de même été suspendu et a
démissionné après 11 mois en poste
[Musique]
à la lumière des allégations de
corruption qui planent compte
l'industrie des visas doré à l'échelle
mondiale nous nous sommes rendus à un
camp afin de vérifier ce que disent
vraiment les consultants et avocats qui
recrutent les candidats au programme
québécois pour pouvoir les approcher
sans attirer les soupçons
nous avons créé notre propre immigrants
investisseurs
son nom d'emprunt et monsieur chen dans
la vraie vie
monsieur chen et chef cuisinier à hong
kong et pour les fans notre mission nous
l'avons transformé en multi millionnaire
de la chine continentale pdg d'une
compagnie fictive djemba au le léopard
doré nous lui avons procuré une adresse
de courriel un cellulaire une assistante
et un chauffard montres suisses et sac à
main de luxe complexe le déguisement
pour être éligible au programme
monsieur chaîne devra faire un prêt sans
intérêt de 1,2 million de dollars au
gouvernement du québec pendant cinq ans
une seule chaîne devra démontrer qu'il
possède une fortune d'au minimum 2
millions de dollars dont les fonds ont
été acquis légalement et il doit aussi
s'engager par écrit à vouloir
s'installer au québec
mais dans notre scénario monsieur chen
déclarera ne pas vouloir s'installer au
québec
préférant envoyer sa fille à
l'université à toronto ou à vancouver
il indiquera que l'origine de sa fortune
et nébuleuses
il dira à posséder une usine de sacs de
plastique dont une partie des documents
administratifs ont été détruits par un
incendie
de plus il dira à exploiter un commerce
de prêt sur gage un penchant carburant
aux prêts usuraires et à l'argent
comptant il avouera qu'une bonne partie
de sa fortune n'a jamais été déclarés
aux autorités fiscales chinoises
nous avons présenté notre scénario
fictif à l'avocat en immigration hugues
l'anglais accepterait-il monsieur
chaînes comme clients je vais vous en ma
réaction est immédiate
oui rendre au canada peu importe
pourquoi pourquoi parce que tout ça
comptabilité tout les éléments
financiers ne sont absolument pas
prouvable qui rien à faire avec ça vous
me présentant les cats de là où j'avais
rencontré jeudi vers sa chair personnage
monsieur chen allez vous faire voir
ailleurs que produit
après la pause vous allez découvrir ce
que vont dire les consultants en
immigration à monsieur chain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est à hong kong que viennent les
nouveaux riches la chine continentale
pour faire leur magasinage dans les
nombreuses boutiques de luxe
plusieurs d'entre eux en profitent aussi
pour ce magazine et des passeports et
des visas vers l'étranger comment les
consultants et avocats en immigration
leurs ventes si le programme immigrants
investisseurs du québec
c'est ce que nous espérons découvrir
lors de notre opération monsieur chen
avec notre millionnaire fictifs et son
équipe dès nos premiers appels des
consultants nous confirme que monsieur
chaîne pourrait utiliser le programme
québécois pour s'installer à vancouver
ou à toronto mais il devra cacher sa
véritable intention
durant l'entrevue de sélection lapoix
vérité marche pour ça cette affaire löw
veut dire toute la base des déclarations
en matière d'émigration cents soit le
fait que ça doutait des déclarations
s'est donc levé la vérité tout est dit
on peut pas se permettre ici de faire un
conseil débats dans une halle aux toiles
de vérité cette année contrairement au
contraire si la loi canadienne permet
aux résidents permanents de se déplacer
à leur guise une fois au canada pour
être sélectionnés les immigrants
investisseurs doivent déclarer par écrit
avoir la ferme intention de s'établir au
québec on doit travailler en fonction de
la véritable province de destination et
non pas détourner la l'intention pour
amener les faire usage d'un programme
d'immigration plus aucun nom
nous obtenons un rendez-vous au cabinet
simard est associé l'avocat sébastien
guimier pas de mauvaise nouvelle pour
muse jane l'avocat québécois lui
confirme cependant qu'il n'aurait pas à
s'installer au québec tout en le mettant
en garde de ne pas acheter de
l'immobilier à vancouver avant d'avoir
obtenu sa carte de résident permanent et
ils ont bien raison
l'assistant de monsieur chen demande
alors s'il devra louer un appartement à
montréal à son arrivée même s'il n'y
habitent pas ce que vous pensez de même
avoir à faire la dernière du cabinet
d'avocats mais ça c'est cet extrait
résider là c'est pas donné l'adresse de
quelqu'un je dois être là sur le
territoire réellement pas de manière
factice je traite le rayonnement et de
donner l'adresse qui l'a du cabinet
d'avocats ou du
je demande la famille sy ne pas y ait ce
devient une fabrication
joint par courriel sébastien qui me dit
qu'il a suggéré louer un appartement
pour la réception de la carte de
résident permanent
si le candidat devait quitter le canada
avant de l'avoir reçu il ajoute que la
question d'intention de s'établir au
québec est délicate puisque le processus
dure près de quatre ans et les
plausibles que de nouvelles
circonstances alter l'intention initiale
il dit respecter la loi au niveau de la
préparation des dossiers de ses clients
[Musique]
des fonctionnaires qui ont travaillé à
la sélection des immigrants
investisseurs à partir du bureau de hong
kong ont accepté de témoigner de leur
expérience nous avons dissimuler leur
identité et remplacer leurs voix en
raison du devoir de discrétion des
employés de la fonction publique à
l'intérieur du ministère personne n'en
faisait mystère que de toute façon les
candidats ne s'installe et pas au québec
c'est quelque chose qui était su qu'ils
étaient assumées al interne et on nous
demandait pas vraiment vérifié les
tensions d'immigrer au québec
le programme exige que les candidats
dévoilent tous leurs avoirs et prouvent
qu'ils ont acquis leur fortune
légalement avec documents à l'appui des
dossiers souvent très volumineux j'en ai
déjà vu deux mains à hauteur de ma
grandeur des dossiers des chemises
empilés puis empilés seuil en avait or
on a loué aux fonctionnaires 7 heures
par candidats y compris la lecture d'un
résumé du dossier
l'entrevue et la rédaction de rapports
les semaines de travail pouvait assez
lourde 60 70 heures par semaine faire ce
travail de diligence ça prend du temps
et on l'avait postant là pour auditer
une entreprise des comptes financiers
d'entreprises ou des transactions
boursières ou même bancaire ça prend
plus que cet art par dossier ces
fonctionnaires qui ont travaillé au
bureau de hong kong entre 2010 et 2017
nous ont fait part de la piètre qualité
des dossiers qu'il devait traiter les
dossiers étaient mauvais de façon
générale je vous dirai plus de 50% les
dossiers quand on les regardait on avait
beaucoup de questionnements beaucoup
d'interrogations d'un programme qui a
beaucoup de failles qui permettent à des
gens qui ont des activités peu
recommandables voir illicite de
finalement blanchir des fonds par
l'entremise de ce programme et s'acheter
une citoyenneté a beaucoup dans bien des
cas les témoignages des candidats lors
de l'entrevue soulevait de sérieux
doutes
auprès de ces fonctionnaires qui nous
cachait beaucoup c'était leurs avoirs et
la source
comment ils ont investi dans une
entreprise comment ils ont investi dans
une propriété
ce que j'ai vu c'est une réalité dans le
discours des candidats qui connaît pas
ou documents c'est beaucoup de documents
faux c'est beaucoup d'histoires montée
de toutes pièces
l'avocat jean françois harvey admet que
le problème de faux documents existent
dans l'industrie mais il blâme plutôt
les exigences documentaire strict du
ministère de l'immigration du québec
d'accueil québec a commencé à trop
pousser cette source de fonds le avoir à
vouloir une source de fonds qui étaient
parfaites avec des reçus d'impôt qu'ils
allaient me pousse à le créer quoi te
créer toute une industrie de fausse
documentation
plusieurs fonctionnaires qui nous avons
parlé disent qu'il subissait des
pressions alain terme pour accepter
davantage de candidats même dans des cas
où des dossiers soulevait des doutes de
corruption en défendant mes dossiers qui
étaient refusés en mentionnant qu'ils
avaient de la corruption liée à un
candidat en justifiant auprès de la
direction
on m'a déjà mentionné que c'est des
choses qui existent aussi au québec
je devais y aller peut-être un peu plus
mollo sur l'interprétation que je devais
faire de l'origine licite des fonds donc
on devait pas être aussi exigeants
puisque la corruption oui oui voilà donc
ça m'avait beaucoup choqué d'entendre
une telle chose
selon ces ex conseiller le but non avoué
dépression visait à boucler les budgets
du ministère
grâce aux frais de traitement des
dossiers de 15000 dollars imposée à
chaque immigrant investisseur avec
environ 1900 dossiers acceptés par année
cela équivaut à plus de 28 millions de
dollars dans les poches du gouvernement
ça se disait que le programme c'était la
vache à lait du ministère on subissait
beaucoup de pression pour justement
accepter plus pour être capable
d'atteindre les objectifs financiers de
l'année
le ministère des migrations nous admet
qu'il a pu y avoir un objectif de taux
d'acceptation à atteindre mais dit
qu'une telle consigne n'est plus en
vigueur
le ministère ajoute que des mesures de
vérification des candidats mis en place
sont efficientes et contribuer à assurer
l'intégrité du programme en 2010 est le
gouvernement du québec a fermé son
bureau de hong kong dans la foulée d'une
ronde de compressions
les investisseurs chinois peuvent encore
être convoqué à une entrevue mai à
montréal
et elles se font beaucoup plus rares
d'après des données obtenues en vertu de
la loi sur l'accès aux documents
le taux de candidats acceptés sans
entrevue a grimpé de façon vertigineuse
au cours des dernières années passant de
14 à 75 % le ministre earth elle a
décliné notre demande d'entrevue par
courriel sont attachés nous répond que
le rapatriement des activités de hong
kong a permis au ministère d'assurer une
plus grande uniformité dans le
traitement des demandes et un contrôle
de la qualité accrue
mais les ex fonctionnaires à qui nous
avons parlé estime plutôt le contraire
c'est sûr qu'on accepte plus
d'immigrants qui ont fait de la fraude
qui ont fait de la corruption tous les
crimes financiers possibles
c'est sûr qu'en faisant ce changement là
les codes fraude rendent beaucoup plus
facilement qu'avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'où des consultants et avocats les
migrations iron team pour vendre le
programme des immigrants investisseurs
du québec
nous poursuivons notre enquête à hong
kong en caméra cachée avec notre
millionnaire chinois fictives
monsieur chen et son équipe
[Musique]
notre prochain rendez-vous est avec le
groupe globo vise à cette importante
firme de consultants en immigration est
basé à hong kong et compte entre autres
des bureaux à toronto et à vancouver
encore une fois on conseille à monsieur
le chêne de ne pas révéler aux autorités
canadiennes que sa véritable intention
et s'établir ailleurs qu'au québec
[Musique]
quand vient le temps de discuter de
l'origine de la fortune de monsieur chen
notre millionnaire fictif lui avoue ne
pas être en règle avec le fisc chinois
la consultante suggère à monsieur chaîne
de ne pas tous déclarés aux autorités
québécoises
elle lui conseille de transférer les
actifs problématiques à une société
enregistrée aux îles vierges
britanniques un paradis fiscal
[Musique]
le site chine lui un vrai aussi que
l'origine de sa fortune et nébuleuses et
qu'ils y effectuent des prêts usuraires
dans son commerce de prêt sur gage
elle a une solution toute faite pour les
cas plus difficile la création d'une
deuxième identité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'autres attentats à des cordes en do
majeur est affecté mahmoudi voilà la
hauteur de notre outing il a un candidat
et enfin thomas cap jon corzine à
tanglewood sida afin que vous irez ya eu
des dents y en a un bout d'oreille omar
audio comme l ego américain larry riley
comme gaby croyant drôle quand ballack
en même temps être soit elle enfin nous
allons mesdames et messieurs jean petit
train a nié ces faits comme des
collections comme le royaume dans les
halls on descendait au manioc ou
théoriques
[Musique]
tout ça c'est frau du deuil
est-ce qu'on a deux dates et non à nos
yeux quand on est à chercher une
deuxième identité parce qu'on a quelque
chose à cacher et dans ce contexte là
aussi je cache quelque chose je
contredis à ce programme qui dit joue à
tous déclaré lise et de question on a eu
des cas plus gris encore des gens qui
passaient paul la vérification niveau
criminel et on leur offre ce moment la
nouvelle identité tout ça si la part des
témoignages comme celui qu'on entend
il est donc possible de contourner
ouvertement officiellement qui a pas de
vérification qui est fait c'est qu'on
donne la possibilité a déjà qu'ils
peuvent frauder et ont fraudé de sentir
et d'obtenir la résidence permanente au
canada par lettre les représentants de
glo visa disent que monsieur chaîne
n'aurait pratiquement eu aucune chance
d'être sélectionné comme clients glos
visa dit que les principaux programmes
de citoyenneté des caraïbes n'inclut pas
un changement d'identité
notre mission à hong kong se termine
avec un rendez vous aux rares villages
où le cabinet mis sur pied par le
québécois jean françois harvey la
représentante du cabinet de jean
françois harvey sung et à se faire
rassurante
lorsque monsieur chen lin forme qui n'a
pas l'intention de s'installer au québec
la représentante du enlevé l'angop
indique elle aussi qu'une simple adresse
résidentielle suffit
nous avons montré ces extraits de notre
tournage en caméra cachée à jean
françois harvey max peut être ce piqué
aux clients de la voile intentions au
québec ça j'avoue ce une erreur grave
sans hésitation je dois quand même
soigné que ce n'est pas une avocate que
vous avez dans la salle mais ce ne sont
pas les dégâts et lorsque notre
millionnaire fictif indiquent qu'ils ne
veut pas déclaré tous ses avoirs aux
autorités québécoises
la représentante du cabinet de jean
françois harvey n'y voit aucun problème
et lui suggère aussi d'utiliser les
caraïbes pour dissimuler une partie de
ses actifs permettant ainsi des cachets
à la fois aux autorités québécoises et
au fisc chinois et il déclaré
quant au fond nébuleux d'une partie de
la fortune de monsieur chen la
représentante du gharb et l'anc est
claire il ne devrait pas les déclarer à
la barre
besoin sinon à un autre ex officier
[Musique]
alors 1 et se présente comme avocate au
cc grâce c'est quand nos propres règles
internes aussi je vais devoir prendre
des mesures va sans dire et de elle dit
que pas besoin de tout déclarer on peut
cacher le puncheur le magasin d'un prêt
sur gage les coûts des mesures doivent
ouvrir les yeux aux sinon quand même tu
vois gueule et des choses qu'ils
n'auraient pas évolué mais d'un autre
côté le processus au bureau si ce client
l'arrêt rencontre un avocat howard -
aura commencé à procéder aux c'est qu'on
aurait vu les trous dans dossier à la
suite de notre entrevue sous guetta a
été congédié durant villard groupe
l'avocat hugues l'anglais est aussi
formateur en droit des migrations
on ne peut pas conseiller quelqu'un
d'agir de manière illégale contraire à
la loi
il croit que jean françois harvey pour
être tenue responsable des propos de son
employé
en vertu du code de déontologie des
avocats il avait créé responsable de ce
qui est dit en son nom pour tenter de
rechercher une clientèle c'est certain
qu'il s'agit d'un conseil donné par
quelqu'un qui en représente à peine dans
un cabinet d'avocats dès qu'on dit
carrément vous n'avez pas déclaré c'est
illégal au sens voici le bilan de notre
enquête à hong kong
à une exception près tous les avocats et
consultant que nous avons contactés ont
conseillé à notre millionnaire fictif de
cacher aux autorités canadiennes son
intention de ne pas vraiment s'établir
au québec et près de la moitié ont
recommandé de ne pas divulguer les
actifs dont l'origine est nébuleux ça me
rend un peu mal à l'aise de voir qu'on
métier un programme avec ses immenses
faiblesses qui sont connues de
l'industrie on semble pas les avoir
corrigé on sent pour vouloir les
corriger
je pense que le gouvernement fédéral est
la bonne solution 2014 était de fermer
le programme
je pense que il faudrait que le
gouvernement du québec songe à fait la
même chose
les visas d'or et est ce que ça
contribue vraiment l'économie québécoise
on vous donne la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
[Rires]
quelles sont les retombées économiques
réelles du programme des immigrants
investisseurs du québec
nous sommes allés visiter la maison
orphée un fabricant d'huile et
condiments de la ville de québec
l'entreprise est en phase d'achat d'un
nouvel équipement 5 % du financement de
ce projet de modernisation proviennent
de subventions du programme des
immigrants investisseurs
c'est toujours un peu la cerise sur le
sundae finalement qui permet d'avoir un
petit peu plus de liquidité cartonné par
une petite entreprise qui n'est pas en
croissance mais les liquidités c'est
toujours ce qui manque c'est un bon
moyen d'avoir un petit coussin
notre entreprise est situé à québec on
est dans le domaine de la transformation
alimentaire - eu une à la maison orphée
est l'exemple qui a choisi l'industrie
des intermédiaires financiers pour
souligner le succès du programme
immigrants investisseurs devant un
comité parlementaire en 2011 donc pour
nous vraiment le site soupe dette
financière est plus que bienvenu et
devrait être plus connu à la même table
des économistes est plus réputé du
québec pierre fourtet fait lui aussi
l'éloge du programme
ça donne un résultat assez incroyable
que près des deux tiers de tous les
immigrants investisseurs qui entrent au
canada
son voeu accueillis par du par le québec
dans une série d'études et de mémoire
pierre fortin crie qu'il s'agit d'une
immigration payante avec un taux de
rendement spectaculaire pour le québec
qui permet de créer des emplois à faible
coût bref il s'agit d'une bénédiction du
ciel
voici comment provient cette même de
l'étranger
il migre investisseurs fait un prêt sans
intérêt d'un montant de 1,2 million de
dollars au gouvernement du québec qu'il
récupérera entièrement après cinq ans
entre temps le québec fait fructifier
ces fonds aux taux d'intérêt du marché
les intérêts générés sont redistribuées
entre autres à de petites et moyennes
entreprises québécoises par le
truchement d'investissement québec la
société de financement du gouvernement
depuis l'an 2000 695 millions de dollars
ont été versés aux pme mais le programme
est aussi une corne d'abondance pour les
intermédiaires financiers qu'ils
soumettent les dossiers des immigrants
investisseurs
pendant la même période le gouvernement
leur a versé 605 millions de dollars en
honoraires professionnels
presque autant d'argent que ce qui a été
versé en subventions aux pme moi je
voudrais d'abord dire une chose sujet
des intermédiaires financiers ce sont
les intermédiaires financiers dont la
banque nationale et desjardins qui ont
financé les études de pierre fortin au
sujet des immigrants investisseurs
monsieur fortin a décliné notre demande
d'entrevue puisqu'il n'a pas travaillé
sur ce sujet depuis quelques années il
nous a référé au co auteurs des études
l'économiste pierre emmanuel paradis
dernier rapport annuel d'investissement
québec on parle de 4000 emplois au total
qui sont liées directement à ces
contributions l'or mais en analysant les
données plus près nous avons remarqué
quelque chose d'étonnant
investissement québec ne finance au
maximum que 10% d'un projet les chiffes
publiés dans ses rapports annuels des
noms 100 % des emplois créés ou
sauvegardés par ce projet
l'impact sur la création d'emplois à
part est dix fois plus élevé qu'il ne
l'est en réalité
investissement québec nous répond qu'il
s'agit de sa façon standard de procéder
et qu'elle ne considère pas que tous ces
emplois sont attribuables à son
intervention ce n'est pas ce qu'avait
compris
l'économiste pierre emmanuel paradis
d'aucuns créés ou sauvegardés ici s'est
attribué à l'ensemble des malades je
pense que personne qui veut dire que
c'est la bonne façon de faire cesser il
faut il faut rendre à césar ce qui est à
césar
si ça va que c'était des mauvaises
données à ce moment là il faut rectifier
le tir alors mesdames messieurs morceaux
et selon la vérificatrice générale du
québec investissement québec ne fait pas
de suivi pour s'assurer que les emplois
annoncés se sont concrétisées un endroit
qui a besoin de gens dynamiques soucieux
de vouloir contribuer à temps les torts
l'arrivée de ces immigrants
investisseurs pourraient amener du sang
neuf dans le monde des affaires
québécois mais en réalité très peu
d'immigrés investisseurs font des
entreprises chez nous si on pourrait
avoir plus d'entrepreneuriat ce serait
mieux mais mais il se trouve que c'est
pas ce qui se passe parce que le
gagne-pain se passe à l'extérieur du
pays vont au programme d'immigration
si les gens restent pas mais quelque
part ça rate sa cible
les revenus du programme eux ont diminué
de façon significative car ils dépendent
des taux d'intérêt des taux qui ont
connu des bas historique au cours des
dix dernières années
le gouvernement vient de hausser le
montant du prêt que doivent fournir les
immigrants mais pour pierre emmanuel
paradis
ce ne sera pas suffisant un défenseur du
programme croit maintenant qu'une
réforme majeurs s'imposent
ça fait trop longtemps qu'on en parle et
moi je suis un grand partisan de
regarder les problèmes en face puis de
les régler puis je crois que ça aurait
fait dans ce cas même après la pause
notre équipe a découvert le lien entre
les visas de ré québécois et le prix des
maisons qui grippent à vancouver la
suite de notre enquête dans un instant
[Musique]
c'est sur la côte ouest à vancouver que
s'installe la majorité des millionnaires
chinois qui sont entrés au canada par le
programme des immigrants investisseurs
du québec
ce programme a bien mauvaise prince ici
car il est en partie blanc mais pour
avoir contribué à la flambée exorbitante
des prix de l'immobilier
le programme québécois était le facteur
principal de l'arrivée de ces régies
migrants ici à vancouver et au canada
c'est un des facteurs qui a mené à la
hausse du prix de l'immobilier ici vous
voyez des propriétés qui valent 5 ou 6
millions de dollars les gens ici n'ont
pas les revenus pour s'acheter de telle
résidence
ce sont des revenus provenant de
l'étranger et une part importante
viennent des immigrants investisseurs du
programme québécois
le journaliste kényan est le
correspondant vancouvérois du south
china morning post
un quotidien publié depuis hong kong il
a été un des premiers ici à faire
enquête sur le programme québécois des
immigrants investisseurs
le programme québécois des immigrants
investisseurs est une magouille du début
à la fin
tous ceux qui participent le savent ceux
qui élaborent les politiques ceux qui
recrutent les candidats et les migrants
eux mêmes savent très bien que ce
programme ne remplit pas les objectifs
visés le cas des migrantes chinoise zhao
jing lee est révélateur son mari ses
enfants et elle ont obtenu leur
résidence permanente en 2006 grâce au
programme du québec
mais la famille n'a même pas pris la
peine de se rendre au québec pour leur
arrivée au pays
ils sont arrivés ici à vancouver et
seulement 10 jours après leur arrivée
ils sont repartis pendant les six sept
ou huit années qui ont suivi leur
présence réelle au canada étaient
minimales
puis en 2014 zhao jing y est revenu
s'installer de façon permanente à
vancouver pour que ses fils ou éduquer
au canada le père lui est resté en chine
pour poursuivre sa carrière d'avocat
c'est ce qu'on appelle communément une
famille satellite
zhao jing lee a fait l'achat avec les
fonds de son mari de cette résidence
luxueuse de 5 millions de dollars dans
la municipalité huppé de west vancouver
c'est un moyen privilégié de garder
votre argent beaucoup d'immigrants
investisseurs veulent simplement retirer
de l'argent de la chine
ils veulent le placer ailleurs que dans
un compte bancaire qu'ils soient
facilement identifiable et l'a ensuite
fait l'acquisition de deux voitures de
luxe l'an couvert est d'ailleurs devenu
la capitale nord-américaine des voitures
de luxe
en réponse à la demande fulgurante des
millionnaires asiatiques
zhao jing lee a comparu l'année dernière
devant la commission de l'immigration
car elle n'a pas vécu au pays
suffisamment longtemps pour renouveler
son statut de résidente permanente
elle s'est fait demander pourquoi elles
ne s'étaient pas installés au québec tel
que leur est dû le faire elle a dit
avoir fait une courte visite à montréal
et que ne connaissant pas le français il
serait trop difficile pour elle de vivre
au québec elle raconté s'être rendu dans
une station service et avoir été
consterné de voir que les gens parler
français ne pouvait pas communiquer avec
elles en ont on pourrait penser que pour
des immigrants qui veulent s'installer
au québec c'est connu que les québécois
parlent le français
en 2016 zhao jing lee n'a payé que 69
dollars en impôts sur le revenu sa
résidence vaut aujourd'hui 8 millions $
nous avons tenté de la joindre à
plusieurs reprises mais elle a décliné
notre demande d'entrevue
l'une des choses les plus ridicules du
programme des immigrants investisseurs
du québec et des immigrants millionnaire
en général et le peu d'argent qu'il
déclare au fisc lorsqu'ils sont au
canada
dans plusieurs cas ils paient moins
d'impôts que les réfugiés
c'est d'ailleurs une des principales
raisons qui ont poussé le gouvernement
fédéral à mettre fin en 2014
un programme similaire à celui du québec
qui avait été mis sur pied pour les
autres provinces
enfin compte c'est la colombie
britannique et l'ontario qui se retrouve
avec les dépenses liées à ces immigrants
mais sans bénéficier des avantages
financiers perçue par le québec
à leur arrivée au québec prend l'argent
c'est vancouver qui paie la facture pour
les dépenses associées à ces gens canada
les frais en éducation en santé pour les
routes ce genre de choses on prenait
l'argent puis ça m'a d'ailleurs est-ce
que c'est est conscient mais je pense
que tout le monde le savait oui c'est
tout le monde savait bien il faut que
courage politique pour changer ce
programme pour que les gens restent
[Musique]
la colombie britannique a adopté des
mesures pour tenter de réduire
l'affluence des capitaux étrangers sur
le marché immobilier en folie vancouver
montréal verra tel phénomène semblable
un jour des signes avant-coureurs death
croire que les spéculateurs fonciers de
la chine continentale commence déjà à
s'intéresser à la métropole québécoise
on espère que vous avez apprécié
l'enquète de ce soir il ya d'ailleurs
plusieurs informations complémentaires
sur notre page web sur cette question
des visas doré au nom de toute l'équipe
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là est revenu
nous laisse une prochaine pour une autre
enquête
[Musique]